don't laugh going laugh but life hello
everyone and welcome to rad table with
the stream team and this is where we sit
and speak to content creators about
their journeys and where they are today
now the past couple of weeks we've had
three amazing guests individually we've
had Papa John with that dr. Bob we had
crispy all a group of vici gaming here
and today I want to bring everything
together for you guys to meet them to
kind of explain to that like you know
explain what wicked gaming is what
they're doing where they are you know
all of their different charities all
that stuff so why don't like I don't
know how you guys want to end up doing
everyone split up abdominus to talk a
little bit of doctor Bob how you guys
want to or you want to talk to Bob to
try to explain it and then Tom work like
fix everything he says or what you like
to do yeah I can be our billboard if you
want to discuss yeah Bob has the most
surface area so if we need a billboard
we usually put him just stand up on the
highway can you read it so you want to
know about the charity the charity yeah
I know we've like kind of did probably
the art or a three ways you know over
the last couple weeks so yeah I mean
let's um talk about the charity first
just so you know people know it so
basically the shirt that Bob's wearing
which says thank you and a couple of
different formats there with a couple of
different symbols those are all
different symbols from different video
games for the healer class you've got
the world of warcraft looking for group
killer symbol there's one for heroes of
the storm there's our logo there I think
that's lifeline from apex I can't see
bottom under that oh there we go
and then that one is from overwatch and
then the other one is from league for
the support healer role so effectively
the idea is you know in an effort to
support the community that raised us you
know we're all Boston guys born and
raised and to obviously prefer provide
health care workers on the front lines
with PPE
which they desperately need
we've been raising money for the Boston
foundations kovat 19 PPE fund so
basically what that does is it'll
provide funding for supplies for
personal protective equipment or and/or
for grants for hospitals and senior care
facilities in the Greater Boston area
affected by Kovac 19 so starting on
April 30th that's when we launched the
shirt we've sold like 35 or almost 40
shirts already actually also didn't
realize this but the Boston foundation
replied to us on Twitter and I'm
literally just now seeing that yeah
fired back at that but that's okay and
then on June 6th we're actually starting
a charity valor in tournament where 50%
of all entry fees and a hundred percent
of all tips and donations during the
tournament will be donated directly to
the Boston foundation so doing a lot of
stuff here we've already got easily over
three hundred dollars raised and we're
not stopping there we're probably I mean
hopefully look into at least crack a
thousand dollars hopefully more so we'll
see how the tournament goes and the
shirts are still flying
I see like one or two emails a day about
those at this point so yeah that's been
that's been pretty great so real proud
of the turnout that we've had so far
that's amazing two things one if you
could put the link in chat if that's
possible and into our Twitter
conversation so I can make sure I can
put that into the news and stuff like
that that will be a link right there to
the tweet and get the chatter now okay
yeah cuz I would love to have that so
you can kind of you know tell everyone
about everything that that's fantastic I
love I love it when people like us in
the gaming you know sphere if you will
give back because I mean it's it's
amazing how gamers kind of just
automatically will kind of mesh to other
gamers and wanting to help I mean
everyone knows of you know the st. Jude
foundation all the that stuff that a lot
of gamers end up doing like the whole
Destiny community does and like you guys
are doing with that with the with giving
back to the charities for that like I'd
do that for animals every year so
it's amazing how people love doing that
and I I'm very happy that you guys yeah
the charity stuffs great we've we've
done a lot of different charity drives
before we every year I shaved my face
with hair into a mustache and raise
money for Movember we raised like over
three grand this past November which is
awesome yeah I mean we we've had some
great stuff we've raised money for a
close personal friends foundation who
you know tragically lost his son when he
was still an infant and we're able to
raise some money there so that really
felt good and it's just kind of I mean
we've been saying this since literally
day zero which was all the money that we
make from the show from t-shirts from
whatever like none of it goes into our
pockets we either get better equipment
to make the show better or do or donate
it to charity like this is something
that we do that feels good and you know
it feels even better when you when
you're able to give back so you know
that's great it would be it would be a
lot better if we do both if yeah if we
could do both and we were getting paid
full time to be doing this and then also
donating consistently to charity but
since we're all working our own jobs
it's like what the [ __ ] like we don't
need to pocket any of the extra money
that we get from like twitch any subs
any donations you like that sales we get
like you we might as well just continue
to perfect our craft and you know chisel
the edges a little bit to smooth
everything out for everybody that
watches our [ __ ] I mean our stuff yeah
yeah one of the things that I just
realized too is like so a lot of these
like sales are still pending through
like the shirts of getting shipped and
stuff but the money hasn't like cleared
to us yet so that we can donate it our
pending sales is probably just a few
shirts away from eclipsing our total
sales in total for like the whole three
years that our shop has been there so
we've almost doubled our total merch
sales and half of that is going to
charity so like I'm looking at a pie
chart for our total pending sales and
eighty percent of it almost eighty
percent of it is that Cogan 19 teacher
so yeah we've almost doubled our total
sales number and half of that is going
to charity so
that feels pretty good it's really cool
I didn't even see that oh yeah yeah
that's that's great
and the thing that's really amazing with
the whole Cove in nineteen
people are so much wanting to help other
people like give them masks like my wife
has been making a whole bunch of masks
for family friends that are working in
hospitals and my one friend he ended up
getting like a huge amount of donations
from from actually a local town for him
to use his 3d printer because he ended
up having three three 3d printers and
he's just mass producing masks and face
shields for people so it's like it's
something that you wouldn't expect the
average person to just want to do and
help there's so many people coming out
of the woodwork for it and I feels
really good and you can do you can we're
all we're all in this together shitty
situations hit everyone I mean the view
if you're not affected directly someone
that you're someone in your family is
one of your good friends is so like
we're all in it together so the least
people can do is at least try to do
their part yes yeah exactly
exactly so um now to come to bring to
bring this you know back around the we
could give games brand if you will so it
is the website the what the podcast
would you buy yeah so what else what
else what else would you say is part of
the brand so I would say the umbrella is
wicked good gaming that is the umbrella
and then with like under that you have
not another game in podcast which is
wicked good gaming product and then we
Bob who streams majority of time on
Twitch like we've talked about I'm not
the biggest streamer in the world Bob
does his thing on there and then we have
a one of the things that we take pride
in and I could speak for myself Elise's
we won our like social media outlets to
kind of be different avenues where
people can you know learn stuff or just
like laugh or just like just kind of
browse and waste time on ours because I
know me personally I don't
always look up blog post to find out
news Twitter is the modern day newspaper
so like if I can scroll through there
and find it it's huge and like we've
built so many we've met so many really
cool people and grew up brand even more
from my social channels that's like
something that we take very serious and
we we grind it out it's it's three of us
so we try to do a lot for just us three
yeah I think we do a relatively good job
at it sometimes we spread ourselves a
little too thin but we knew what we were
getting involved with but at the end of
the day we get [ __ ] done yeah I said
this in a I'm gonna put quotations here
a pitch meeting that we've done
literally everything in the gaming
industry outside of making our own video
game basically we've done everything
we've we get the website we get the
podcast we stream we have a youtube
channel we have our social media
engagement we've built a community in a
in discord then we never expected to
build we attend consistent conventions
we have connections in the network in
gaming in general with major development
companies we're given access to reviews
and whatnot so but we've literally done
every know the next step that we can go
from here is all right what kind of
video game do wanna make what one thing
with us like we numbers are one thing
right everyone we live in an age now
where it's all about how many zeros you
have have on the end of like your
followers but to us its engagement over
followers I'd rather have four quarters
than 100 pennies and we have people that
we've met with in our community that
literally like so my birthday was
yesterday
there's people is gonna say happy
birthday have a continue well thank you
so there's people literally within the
community community that sent me like
gifts and decorations like for my room
so we could get on a zoom call and right
before we all got on I was out like noon
yesterday Jess who's someone that we
know very well she texted me she was
like hey go outside so I went outside
and there was like two big bags of food
there yeah yeah that was actually
coincidentally timed with me showing up
at your house with a bottle of champagne
I called Chris and I was like hey come
outside and bring two glasses
kid comes outside looks like he just
just rolled out of bed comes out with
two two mismatches glasses and some of
them's like a gladly the stemless wine
glass they would definitely be sitting
in there from the from the time and that
you moved in splash watch them a little
bit with the sink and bone they were
right there and put all those up with
champagne at OJ's all mindedness look at
short what's going on we haven't a good
night tonight at work so I got a stop I
got the wicked Lords in the round fill
it chilly
I'll see MJ MJ there's a don't shrink he
was a little depressed very pleasant
surprise
absolutely I saw your name pop up and I
was like wait I don't know if it's like
just where they do things like Booker T
music to start literally literally just
beat cop head 25 I wanted to murder
myself it's so [ __ ] hard I look I did
a quick two minute review at the end of
it I give it a 9 out of 10 the game is
[ __ ] incorrect
the game is FN incredible the graphics
the graphics are incredible it's like
you're watching an A
nice cartoon with color the music is
good but as I was explaining at the end
it's like I want to listen to my own
music and jounin when I'm like hyper
focused you know and then the gameplay
is nothing seems unfair in the game it's
like if you can't do it yourself
I just get better at the game animation
I feel like mix-up of how game is the
difficulty of it just pushes it over the
edge but you always say before like I
was mad that um didn't cuphead promise
co-op all online co-op and willfully
yeah there's a there's a workaround to
it there's no direct way to do it but
there's they literally tell you that
there's a way to remote play in with
somebody else
yeah but they can't you can't just like
team up with somebody on Steam you know
the easy way to do it or come out of the
woodwork now yeah you see I see a photo
cut out the what that's was so bro
[Music]
but the now the speaking of hand-drawn a
started playing that Street Streets of
Rage for it is so hard man I forgot how
hard those games you play solo I just
started playing it solo yeah I just
wrote let's look up yeah absolutely yeah
an Xbox cuz you know it's on game pass
you know I downloaded a free is just you
know it's on a whim well I didn't even
know was coming to game bass I didn't
even know my side I was gonna download
it for switch just out of curiosity but
I'm glad I got a chance to play it on
game pass at least first so I could get
a feel for it cuz man that game is not
forgiving at all not at all oh I will
say there's no when you unlock the old
retro characters when you beat it they
mad Oh P cuz I guess cuz they can't do
the special moves the newest vegetables
they got the old one where the cop comes
out and they shoot the ping and then
they got that but their basic moves is
bad Oh peel
oh man so I guess they did it for
balancing cuz they figured I guess they
couldn't committee yeah you just
literally have to do playthroughs and as
you go to each stage there's a meter and
each starts to rise
yeah then each one you'll unlock your
lock and then its achievement front
unlock of different actors so it
supports multiple playthroughs really
cool shot the ghost is afraid what's
going on I haven't pledged [ __ ] to regen
decades um I was watching someone play
it the other day I was like I gotta get
back on these I was uh I think it was
the first one the soundtrack was so
strange but so good that the same the
music declines from the first I was like
I miss like the old like be boo bop like
melodies that they have yeah like vibing
out to it but it's so like electrifying
feels so good you're like oh I like this
I want to go dancing because it's like
it's 90s club beats
I mean it's a huge part of a game I like
old me used to be like who cares I'm not
playing it for the music but like now me
that it's like in this body in this age
of Mike all right well I just kind of
want it so no and like play a game like
sometimes the music's nice I don't care
about the game I'll just stand in the
same spot
yes do not even play the game the
control is down two feet to stop front
little chair you know use rocket @cc
music fact pump up the jam was 8 no
sometimes I'll dial up like GTA and just
play the radio bro the radio and GTA is
better than radio in real life folks my
mind so that would you know what can you
guys talk about that it's a real shame
that I can't participate a win but like
will be shown you're more than welcome
to I mean you know the the broadcast
booths only big enough for two of us
yeah Chris let's get it let's go to that
booth to act like you'd knock the floor
with people but he's also like
protecting themselves in case he got
beat up run through everyone don't need
to say you don't need to this is like
giving out the Krabby Patty secret
recipe stop
1% evil 99% hot gas do you play uh cough
have you played it let me let me tell
you how many people have asked me to
just play tarkov on stream it's over 25
it might be we might be reaching like 40
at this point
I've never played it it looks
interesting but it's like there's way
too many games out right now that I want
to play I put too much time at the
counter-strike I put too much time in a
Valerie
like I just had this I hit the the speed
bump or it's like I just want playing a
couple of nice single-player games now
which is why I burned through cuphead
over the weekends knock off some the
complete opposite you lose all your
stuff if you die you know how freaked
out it is zero
like hand-holding yeah here you go
we're gonna give you a handgun and a
chest piece and like there's no HUD you
don't know where your teammates are I
have literally if you go to my YouTube
page
it's literally me shooting my teammates
in the head because I thought they were
enemies like yeah that would drive me
nuts
it's they got the friendly fire oh you
got Merc your man oh yeah like I can't
tell you how many times I've gone into a
raid with a friend's he's playing me in
my head just to take my weapon and not
and tell me all I it wasn't me yo dude
that's a phony I did yeah how's that
Valerie Drano
okay planet so how is it MJ is good you
like it hmm
it's like csgo and overwatch oh it's
just not as good as a dead game over I
just definitely their like the most
notable player left
overwatch to go play again a go play
Balor n'e Lee oh I know Dillon beta and
he left like his career like the game
that made him wow that's crazy yeah and
he was like it was like a defending
champion for like some League he was on
they keep USA that ended up winning
everything he was like it needs like a
20-year old like 20 or 21 he's a big
deal he was like now I'm good with
overwatch I'm gonna go play Balor and a
game that no one even knows there's
nobody to know
crazy I wanted a slim some bread nope
anyway you what you saying about the
tournament cute kind of just started to
talk about it Chris oh yeah yeah so
we're gonna we're gonna host a
tournament on June 6th I believe and
what its gonna be is everyone will buy
their way into the to the tournament and
50% of that we're gonna donate to the
charity in Boston that is helping out
with kovaydin and frontline workers no
and then obviously there'll be a little
incentive for the players to play they
could walk away with something I mean
it's gonna be streamed and show casted
by all three of us so me balisong will
be on the microphone show casting the
whole thing it should be a good time
we've done them with multiple games were
we don't know how it's gonna be with
valor and I know there are people that
will play and really take it serious
other games that we've shale castle was
we did apex yeah I think we've done a
fortnight one too and that might be it
maybe a call they want to do but it's
not it take it's like very
time-consuming we're like you gotta set
everything up and you have to like you
have multiple tabs open switch rooms 105
difference now Chris is we can do all
custom lobbies all we have to do is
create the what's it called the brackets
that's it we get brackets we go we run
customs only best of one one at
single-elimination and we just stream it
for like a couple of hours and you know
it's it's that it's so much easier doing
it that way than it is having to monitor
15 other people's streams of FX or
fortnight
Zoomers like we have full control of it
if people if people want to join that
how are they able to join there's a
couple of people in chat are saying yeah
so I actually we just made a channel and
our discord I did put a I don't know if
I oh wait maybe I did yeah I pasted it
in there the there's a Fowler in June
6th channel and our discord which I put
in there details are to come on that
Chris is like the tournament architect
guys so I'm gonna let him kind of figure
out the details for all that will get
everything
basically what we're gonna do I believe
that we were wanted to do ten total
teams I think we were gonna do a $50 buy
and part team obviously all of the all
of the tips and donations and everything
like that that we received during the
tournament will all go right to the
Boston foundation and then 50% of the
winnings will go to the foundation as
well 50% of like the pot to buy and will
go towards the tournament also go to the
charity as well so yeah I'll put the
disc or link in that one more time put
that up in there I need to hear them
Boston access shoutcasting we don't
answered an apex of Legends tournament
before that was great but we were
sweating our balls off in Chris's
bedroom I was sitting right next to we
both have like a suit and tie on oh we
were doing the Chris Collinsworth see if
I can find the picture of it because I
remember when we first did it and people
were crying laughs and because obviously
they didn't expect us have like a pseudo
why I had a suit on I think Dom only had
a hoodie on but we should sit for the
one out yeah sure you'll be able to see
us it'll pop up there in one second it's
just a video yes and I think we probably
have like a dozen drinks each during it
blod Bob Eubanks I gotta see that it's
clean maybe I'll compete actually that's
funny no I got I got one really really
funny question how did it start that
everyone this has been ragging on Bob
all the time great question here let me
move let me mute you Gigi punching bag
no he's no this
he's like no no everybody was a bit yeah
look he can go here we go dog no but
everybody wants to put called me Bob is
on the offensive 24/7 he does not
there is no you don't even need to hit
him to get him going he's just like
there's always good that's he makes
himself to target and then he's like
picking on me picking on me the whole
time whatever where we're from if we
like you like I like how we are if we
like you we make funny we crack jokes
like exactly like how we show each other
that we just love Bob a whole lot if I
did not know Bob and rail I thought
would think he was one of the most
insufferable human beings but I will
give him it he's able to take it and
like give it back so it's like it's fun
it's fun banter at this point like when
I call Bob a fat [ __ ] do I mean it yeah
but like I don't want to yeah I mean it
Stig did we all make fun of Chris for
being you know having no food in his
fridge and for being pasty and skinny up
you know and forget the topics Bob you
know it's a self-explanatory me for
begin a thousand years old so just
self-explanatory it to me but no we just
do it cuz we love each other and we know
that's like a big New York thing to
that's how you know that's why we can
will we clicked right away we all just
like just just to we go at all times
yeah if we care about you it's because
we love you that's all and that's that's
like 95% of our community - 5% 5% is
just like hey really enjoying the show
and then the other 95% is like wow Bob
you looking big this week good job Mia
gray and out in Chris you look like
Casper the Friendly Ghost okay I need
something
my thing is I can't sleep after like
after a night like grant owes like a
virtual night I didn't go anywhere but I
went to bed I like whatever was like
three and I was up there like 7:30
sorry I don't sleep then like I'm
exhausted at the end of the day that's
crazy I was telling the guys before cuz
they told me that you were drinking
partying and I was like no way nowhere
wow they ever ever ever able to do that
no boys getting busy oh yeah we know
what he says they're gonna do it then
you blink and it's the sun's coming up
[ __ ] you guys drank with us you get it I
left I had a hard out at midnight you
were late don't even start I knew it I
remember you and I got that second floor
you was I still say it I don't know how
I got back to my hotel room and Peter
and I'm like yep getting in the back
seat and next thing what are you here
for
Oh PAX East oh we're here I'm like okay
cool next thing you're back in New York
people ban PAX East Bay it's still
locates my favorite you know it's then
we've done III and it's great and it
spectacle and all that pax it's nothing
a whole different here it's a whole
different way that's why I like el you
gotta get out there when you get a
chance no well MJ you've been you know
Sam but um now you official you can
really go out add to it yes but on is so
much fun like I can't wait for things to
get back to normal because that's yeah
I'm I feel I feel like pax is way better
also for meeting people yes like I feel
like meeting people at pax is way way
way better than trying to like meet over
social media yes like people in social
media they could totally like you know
blow you off but like if you end up big
seeing like a guy on pax and being like
hey you mm I like you you're cool hang
out and then come hang out and then we
end up making that contact like the guys
from was cool from Deep Silver
like Rickon yeah they would though and
Toby like I would never have a rapport
with those guys if I didn't end up
meeting those guys absolutely okay cake
pulled up I see you would
government David Johnson you need to got
the leg check the damn bro Hey Ferno up
in there yo what's up yeah fer don't put
me on a path he told me a long time ago
before he was like you're gonna like
patch warden III he told me he's what I
put me on shout the boss do you see more
photos come on there's so many there's
so many opportunities our packs and like
piggyback what people saying to social
media is a whole different beast where
you can be whoever you want to be but
one more face to face you and put on too
much yeah yeah and like not even from
like a confrontational stamp was like
you I I have a good like BS detect I
know if you're not who you are but then
shows you mean you could literally be
anyone you want so when you're at PAX
axe and it's just like a normal
conversation and I think what helps us
in Boston has a lot of people majority
people better at that joke don't talk
like us and we're in our hometown from
here where do I go get food like what's
the best place to go get a coffee blah
blah blah and we've made so many good
connections that way like mom's a social
butterfly so Dom with the bartender's
I'm like the janitor and absolutely yeah
we uh I mean it's kind of weird because
at PAX I mean it's it's a local show
mm-hm you know it's our like our
hometown it's a nuts on our turf right
but like we still it's still kind of
weird because we're like a there's so
many people travel from so far away that
it kind of feels like we're still like a
novelty that people like oh my god you
guys are actually real like I feel like
I'm a character at Disneyland cuz they
they go like oh my god people actually
have accents here and I would say that
the thing that I found amazing for you
guys and I think I don't remember which
guys we were talking about it with was
when you guys were walking into the
predator party and they couldn't find
you on the list and then they will and
that person that were anything was like
oh you're wicked
oh they're good they're good just just
let them in just let the biggest flex I
could ever say am I like a man is like
no no I got this like I know these guys
go I saw us on the second row I had like
my hoodie in my hand like you're gonna
know us by the end of the night I was
yelling at team NV on stage the poor
appetizer like and there was like ten of
us total she came through and I was like
oh look at this one over here look to
get the scallops over here we were like
all past us they always came to us like
those people like I really don't want to
be here but I'll just watching these
guys because I know they look at their
whole tray it was tell you look over
like we're pounding drinks and what
bigger than like normal people all you
have to see is like Dave and Bob and
yeah they're gonna get ready for my
total volume you see poll you see Red
Hulk and Green Hulk and was like the
earth-616 version of us it's like
ultimate like Marvel ultimate and then
like regular universe we've recorded on
like a podcast like Pete and I were
talking about it I think we all talked
about it like on our separate shows
those probably one of the funnest
podcasts I've ever done the whole script
- it's like right on the floor don't we
had to set up right there it was no that
was that's one of the most fun podcast
organic man when it's organic
sometimes it's just even better exactly
oh that's how it should be that's how
everything should be just like I know I
keep going back like the whole like
preaching the Internet is a terrible
thing but like you it's all about
authenticity just be yourself like
so don't stop trying to be other people
we literally sit down never met each
other in real life well I have met you
guys in real life but we just sat down
and chopped it up like we've known each
other for years an axe that's that's
because you were completely mi afer a
year before or a year before I was off
the vodka redbulls Bros Christmas he was
bent over in a 45 degree angle one of
the tables were talking big what's up
next level gaming yeah something
different this is I'm crashing P DS you
know the boss could do that the boss
could do that right he came through it
for a surprise inspector wicked good
hello a little something that wicket was
here you know right I'd be drinking what
you guys considered water my body loves
me although the water's coming in like
all my organs are like [ __ ] boys we
got some the merengue was a merengue you
know my funny my boss fun is Chris
moment is you running down Tom funny
when you ran him down that was hilarious
I mean the content like that doesn't
present itself all the time so if you
have if you haven't run tf2 take
advantage of it I didn't do it for me I
did it for the people everybody people
we just give it back
did I brew in a poor my 14 year old
girls day yeah I did wasn't worth it I
feel bad but it was working so for four
wicked games like as you know you guys
are together what would you guys say is
your biggest highlight the biggest
you know Perl moment of you know your
career fruit wgg I was where do I start
I died dead lifted a truck off of a
trapped family while picking a gaming
sweatshirt yeah they know where it's
going they know where it's going uh
moments get those moments i promo like i
think last year's pax not this most
recent one no no I take this back two
years ago two years ago for pax we threw
a PAC C's after party on Thursday we did
it two years in a row we didn't do it
this past year because it was it's like
a little too much work you know what I'm
saying it's like too much we have to put
into it but the first time we we threw
it we got featured in the PAX East after
parties you should be attending Wow and
we sold the place out we packed it
wall-to-wall it was probably I would say
that's bad that was like my peak right
there so far because who knows what's
gonna happen in the future
but like being in that bar packed
wall-to-wall with a bunch of sweaty
nerds who were walking around pax all
day just wanted to drink and hang out
that was probably the coolest moments
that I've experienced with us so far
outside of like the fact that our
community has grown to something we've
literally never expected like that and
that's a continuous growth - that's
that's something that like I'll turn it
to our discord because I might just grow
it open all the time
I'll look in and there's at any given
moment 30 people talking at the same
time inside yeah damn we created that
that's we have that's dough this is
weird you wanna go I have to think of
another one because Donna Bob just took
my eye Bob well you also forgot in that
story is when we were outside before the
party started oh yes
those two people that she uh they showed
up and they came up to their semi excuse
me was that like the wicked good gaming
after party gods down see as I go in in
blah blah blah and I heard an accent so
I was like oh you guys from they go from
Chile but we just hear the kind of demo
our game in yadda yadda and then I was
like ah what brings you here they go oh
I love what I love with a good game she
was like I I was assigned listen to the
podcast and like I do all the stuff I
was like she was like you think like the
three like guys are gonna be at times
like yeah two of them are right in front
of you take a picture with us and
everything it was really cool I mean
you're looking a lot skinnier tonight
you don't have to make up stories about
things but like other than that it's
easy to talk a light talk about like I
don't know stats and accolades and stuff
like that but from a strictly like
feel-good standpoint I have to go a bob
on it like seeing people that are from
all around the country like come
together with like a common thing which
is just like yeah and it's so cool and
like it gives gives people place to be
themselves which is really cool and like
you could jump into a boy shot with any
one of us at any given time because
we're probably in one and and like you
guys could attest to it's just like
hanging out with a friend you just jump
in and we're just hanging out
yeah alright so I got like a real answer
and then I got like a cocky answer so my
son taking a page out of my my actual
biological father Tom Brady's book is my
favorite crowning achievement is the
next one so that's that's the cocky
answer but so can you answer the real
answer is and actually you know had a
couple of tweets about this last week
but basically I mean kind of taken like
a page from Ababu saying like the
community as a whole is just something
that I think all of us are incredibly
proud of and that none of us could have
seen coming ever you know I think even
when we first started a discord we had
you know a handful of people in there we
were like write it somebody should go in
and like suggest a topic every day they
like get conversation going
we don't even do that I'll log in and
there's 90 messages that are unread on
my own how humbling is it regular lady
that before you even start yeah and you
know the journey where you came from
before when it was happening which is
why it feels so much better
hey thanks bro same like we don't have
the biggest community but like what I'm
proud of really is just how much our
community cares for one another um like
when it's somebody's birthday they get a
happy birthdays I don't even know how
they know like I don't know if it's like
one person brings it up once and
somebody takes a note of it and then
it's like oh my god it's this person's
birthday and everybody's adding that
under all and down every single week
like if we raid somebody and like a lot
of our regulars stream as well we raid
somebody they flood their stream with
solos birthday wishes like there's
people that are like now friends that
speak on a daily basis that met through
our discord that I never would have ever
ever ever put in the same yep like yep
it's fear at once
yeah I'm so proud of that yeah and yeah
and like they just show such like a deep
and genuine love for one another and
like you you can't fake it and the fact
that like you know people are like we
have people with kids in our discord and
like you know they hop in like a chat
and we like hear them in the background
well I hate when how's it going you know
tell her I said hi like you know it's so
funny don't like just get like people's
families are now a part of our community
and that's what I'm most proud of I'm
just very appreciative and very grateful
and it's like these were already awesome
people these were clearly already great
people and for some reason we're the
centerpiece of that Venn diagram mmm
like we have nothing to do it that we
just have attracted some incredible
people who just are continuing to just
be great together and that's what I'm
most proud of is that we were able to
somehow be that middle piece that that
middle of the Fen diagram that and we
have this like we were just saying like
you know we rip on each other because we
show love or you know that's the way we
show love and affection and like people
in our community do that and they're not
Boston people they're not even like New
York people we have people from the
Midwest we do from the west coast and
they've kind of adopted that like way of
showing love to you know
and to have them kind of take a little
bit from us and like take that tune and
feel that comfortable with each other it
means more than I can put into words
absolutely Ruth what in a song count at
that point right I'm so good with its
words I hate it Lulu like if I try to
put that together with tripled my words
15 times I would sneeze of bees I'm
gonna tell you me I got so much respect
for Dawg yo your host game off the top
freestyle is crazy like but we did that
live and what you cause I oh yeah yes
beg feed people understand oh it's not
easy man put into the podcast in general
it's just it's super difficult because
you know you gotta find you gotta get
your guests together you gotta get your
topics together you got to have you know
a cohesion with your team and your your
podcasting with you know there's so many
different factors and people don't
understand it and the thing that's
amazing about you know the the W Gigi's
team and you know even the ILP team is
that you know you can't do it alone and
you guys have this like supporting
members that you're with like you guys
have each other and like we have all of
our teams together on our side so it's
it's if people actually they understood
how difficult it was they would
appreciate it even more yeah it's just
wild to see like people connect and and
you know again to just literally like go
like this and then just have see the
disc or just go you know what I mean on
a daily basis people supporting each of
the streams you know like people
supporting just each others you know
creative stuff like we have a channel
for just people cooking like like we
were posting food so I made a everybody
was closed in food in the general
channel so I made a home chef Channel
and now that everybody's like hyping up
each other's meals that thing you know
they're like hey Steve you know bacon
egg and cheese on deck you know it's
crazy just to see that stuff and I think
it's just it's amazing just to see what
you know other people have done with the
dough women so it feels really good and
a bit up brothers enough out of the
three of you who is the best chef
dumb oh my god I can barely not burn a
bagel like I can burn a bowl of cereal
[Laughter]
I do if you if you've listened to the
podcast at least once you know exactly
what Chris has in his fridge is it's
been the same for the last three years
oh bottle of mustard and a half drank a
bottle of margarita mix and that's it
yeah my arena mixes from 2011 it's
probably three years old like it was
there when he moved in do you want this
house again like it's still good to
worry about this house is great we got a
washer and dryer we have an in unit
bottle of margarita mix yes you did so
who do you feel is the funniest I'll do
a countdown if you all want to just
scream your option out crazy I would say
Chris just because for me like I feel
like I am you know I can prepare funny
material you know I mean and I think I'm
really good improvising but like Chris
could read the back of a cereal box and
I pissed myself laughing well thank you
that's the thing is like I Chris is just
funny without even intentionally not
even like laughing at him or with him
it's just like unintentionally but when
he's attempting when he's attempting to
read that's when we're laughing at him
my mind works in a very unorthodox way
we're like we could be talking about
like the Red Sox game and I'm thinking
about like a trash barrel I thought it's
like stuff that's always moving around
in my head it just doesn't make any
sense like I I think what plays into it
when I was young guy you should have
weird offs with one of my friends
his name was also cursed we shop widowed
so we just say like random words at one
another and it would last like a half
hour because we just like we thought of
think of the most ridiculous stuff so
maybe I played into it I just thought of
a great business opportunity you have to
start doing that ASMR or whatever it is
and you start reading like cereal boxes
made with high fructose corn syrup
videos with like like weird things I'll
do it with like a bear like a jewel or
something wicked good and I always
misspelled to do amsr or something like
that just correct me did the engagement
up now we need now we need a real heavy
question like let's go I'm gonna throw
this layup to like who's the best blank
and among yes who's the best it's a
gaming podcast who's the best gamer
great question great question Pete great
question people that you want to count
down again and one two three Bob I'm
gonna decide not to answer this one that
dog was that dead Mike okay I will say
this I this is what I will say cuz I
think like best gamer is a bit of a
loaded question
oh I will say this no I will say this if
like if we had to do like a trial by
combat and like my life depended on it I
needed to pick a champion to like defend
me and like if they lost in this game I
would I would actually die in real life
yeah I would pick Bob oh if anybody I
ever met that might be the sweetest
thing you've ever said well I'm just
saying and I've I have I have competed
on a beer pong table with Bob and I know
that it doesn't it actually doesn't
really make a difference what it is
because and I've been watching the last
dance on Sundays and I've been seen like
you know I mean it's like repetitive
juices yeah the competitive juices start
flowing
and and he's just not of this earth it
just goes away it's a primal yeah it's a
primal instinct yes that not many people
have and I've seen Bob come back from
you know on insurmountable odds to pull
off wins that other people like it's
obnoxious and I'm like I'm so glad that
we're on the same team right now because
I would be so mad if I was those guys Oh
the story should we tell them the story
of little beer pong we got to hear the
story about the beer pong annex may give
you $2 glorious my god I'm just happy to
see what's faces on I'll finally know
real quick this was like the yes oh the
condensed version of this is no Bobby's
gonna want God you took there like I
went to the bar right 20 army and I had
to go get change and then fast forward
you like John playing a game and then
there's this kid looking at me from
across shot up didn't have they didn't
have change for the $10,000 bill I had
in my pocket so no so long story show
this was like two paksas ago I think PAC
CSIS is the pathetic play days uh
after-party like midday party thing we
just pretty Siviglia there all weekend
if you want to know where to find us of
axis usually we love the guy y'all put
me on today so we just stand-in there
you know we're having a couple beers and
um they did away with all so I just want
to go on record and say that I have not
seen a beer pong table since since this
incident ruled the event for everybody
it was like an open kind of middle it
was also kind of like weirdly just in
the middle of everything so people were
playing beer pong you know it's like you
know get a couple games and we're
getting loose getting ready for the
after-party and you know we were
kind of doing our thing so me and Bob
end up on a table and I remember that
there was these two guys that were just
getting really they were just like
starting to chirp at people I don't know
dumb you weren't even this was the game
after this the game after this yeah I
played with some random woman yeah so we
were like randomly playing you know we
just kind of like whatever some people
weren't even finishing their games they
would just like throw a ball on a cup
and like go get a beer and leave so so
Bob was like I want to play I want to
play I got next I'm gonna get on the
table and so we played a game and won
and then Bob got on with like some
random girl who was standing there and
then the guy it was playing against
those two guys some some girl was just
like waiting her turn
you know patiently just wanted to play a
casual game of beer pong little did she
know she was getting into this with Bob
so into this I like that this way yeah
this poor girl can't hit a cup to save
her life
I mean you know she's just she's just
like whoops like constantly me like I
can't hit a cop why and she was like
having fun she was like having fun with
it whatever like wasn't really getting
too bent out of shape until the two kids
on the other side of the table started
talking [ __ ] and they were like oh sure
you guys are getting ran like that and
like this was all fun it was all good
just a week ago oh man I was just I was
there and I was like hey come on let's
just play the game like good yeah and it
was like nobody was even really paying
attention and then I heard one of those
kids being like oh [ __ ] like you got a
sock or something and I was like oh no
oh no there we go
hoo-wee and so I'm standing there and
then bob was like oh well I don't lose
so that's what the coming to you so they
came back I'm almost positive I am
almost positive they were losing by
about six cups and these kids couldn't
hit a last Cup to save their life I mean
couldn't hit water if they fell out of a
boat and just I mean just I think they
were terrified honest and just petrified
how no time outs Bob starts nailing cups
left and right knees look I don't lose
and you know Bob hits last cup and goes
right up into this kids face and it's
just like I already told you let's go
let's go dude
they were they were trying to be like
tough guys and they were like taking out
their business cards because apparently
they also do yeah throwing them down on
the table after they hit a cop stop it
and I wish I know buddies and I saw I
think like six in a row and I took out a
stack and I threw the stack on top of
the table and they threw it off the
table and I was like oh that was the
biggest mistake you've already big
trouble they mention someone else
playing beer pong again I was doing like
the Dragon Ball Z that everyone was
firing up he was like yeah and I was
typing them up I was like yeah after
them talking a big game the whole time
and then I shut them up afterwards it
came up to me they were like hey man
sorry like we didn't we didn't mean to
like and I was like hey dumb I turned
her out ice how many else have we taken
this weekend and before he could say
jumped in his face I said zero he walked
away and I don't think they've ever
played beer pong since MSB car pong was
concluded in tax and that's why we don't
have those tables will challenge me
don't challenge me and don't make it a
competition when it doesn't need to be a
man it was all good it was all good they
did not have to get to that get that far
and then it's just I was like all you
had to do all you had to say was nothing
takes everything has a competition there
was someone eating on the other side of
the room Bob runs off you think you
could do fast
[Laughter]
I was just trying to I was trying to let
this poor girl who's waiting in line for
like 25 minutes to just play just hey
not even then I don't care if we won or
not because it wasn't competitive to
start until they started
right he was playing then they started
chirpin and I kicked in at the ranked
bow we've been chatting in like MJ I'm
sorry I'm sorry do you guys do GL do you
have any questions or anything you want
to talk about with the guys no I feel
like this is their well you guys got a
dog sounds like we can stop playing with
a dog I will say there should be no
option like pax is like the one place or
I could say that I go and like I feel
like nerd heaven is like there I think I
don't know I've been to comic-con zone
no it's it's a different type of nerd it
really is cool nerds it's yeah I love
going to the Renaissance Fair because I
feel like that's like a safe haven but
like PAX East is like so much different
levels to it as low as to it but it is
camaraderie right it's camaraderie its
accessibility it's a lot but it's a lie
the whole thing feels like a reunion
really pax is just kind of like I mean
you just see people that you've been
talking to or like coordinating with for
so long and you know it's just awesome
to just you know you finally like see
somebody that you haven't seen in like a
year like when we reunited after at the
party or like actually I randomly saw
King before because we had two separate
interviews and Bob texted me he was like
oh I just saw the ILP guys I was like oh
[ __ ] I gotta find them then like I mean
again you can't miss Bob yeah there's
two biggest was there okay
Oh out in like a clearing people like
give him they're giving him a wide like
Avenue like the given he's a man in
space which he deserves and I saw him
and it was just
it was like a Giffen a except see their
friend over to chat earlier and get to
see the new people and then even the
devs like it's just everybody is just so
accessible and cool and it's out like
the expression I told Dom it's like
everybody's got they new mixtape they
read in the show their game like you
don't gotta hunt them down and go
through red tape I won't say there's no
MJ the boss earned his name yes but I
won Pat who's the boss for you bro
that's soda yeah when you hook this up
we got the day's go to dinner I was like
okay MJ we really want to talk to Sony
MJ's like come I got this whole like
this and then you know we're doing our
thing and I'm just like do you need
somebody to talk to say that's like Dom
Dom's our mom when it comes to packs you
didn't send appointment for us come on I
gotta work I missed the first three solo
episodes
refika says I gotta pull up for at least
the last one good people your family is
always love week always loved chemistry
is there again salute the PD table
stream and Jay L bugs la boogie excuse
me Steve I had to show some love even if
it's for a little hot Minnesota check
everybody that pulled up today back in
the realm - for real yes absolutely King
Don I think only yeah the Bob and Chris
you guys have not been on yet No
we got to do it we got to definitely do
it know where to find me
there are over Tom do you want to give
us your your places to find you and
anything you want to talk about before
you head off yeah I'll put in the
discord one more time in the in the chat
so you can see that but yeah I mean you
know what a find us man with its
twitter.com slash wicked good games
everything else is a tour slash wicked
good gaming you could find us at wicked
good gaming calm if you want that
artisinal written content and then man
if you if you want the highly you know
the highly curated you know written
content that's wicked good gaming calm
and then if you want to find the podcast
that is not another gaming podcast and
you can find us on Spotify Apple podcast
Google Play Music stitcher tune in radio
cast radio calm and I Heart Radio and
anywhere fine podcasts are available
just like but yeah so and yeah that's
always it's always nothing but love in
the realm it's so great to hang out with
you guys we appreciate the the invites
you know we hope to do lots lots more
stuff oh yes much stuff as we possibly
can absolutely man absolutely you guys
come in here I want you guys to speak
here speak what you were going on and
then I started hearing the rumbles that
you guys were doing all the the charity
events and I was like this is kind of
like a perfect kind of like thing for
all of us to kind of get together also
to say hey what's going on definitely uh
yeah look at the charity shirt link in
there we'll do all that into the podcast
I'll put it into the description also
into into this one world said and done
so make sure all that is good for for
you guys so so talk to you out do you
want to do your outro yes
I'm just here I'm the glass eye it's
cold out didn't I tell you that what I
think about now it is fun to just pull
up and not be responsible for that
that's perfectly fine no we were talking
about MJ we're kind of like what are we
gonna do with this how's this gonna go
and I was like no format just you can't
before you can have a format with the
three of us on it yeah Jared oh man look
I didn't win all that good stuff my
little podcast you already know Friday
the last word cats out kickass statues
King will be coming back with some new
new joints you know I'm saying this week
and obviously Lord's a game of dinette
all the riders everybody please salut
I see gwg lady infamous in their members
is yo salute grown women game a lot of
people in chat today good to see X bar
good to see Inferno a lot of y'all short
support the table stream PD people do
good work MV I need you how to talk more
stop talking dammit I'll keep it up the
good work low with John Dillon is salute
shot I gotta work my boss Tony croak
well games you're building Bob in a
building so Bob Chris yeah so I'm a
company man so I'll probably end up just
repeating the same thing that Dom said
socials at Wicca gaming besides Twitter
it's at wicked good games because we
can't fit gaming in it that it's don't
allow that many characters in it yet
written content wicked goog amacom
podcast on all those platforms Dom said
and then kind of within there you can
find us individually we're in the bio on
our Twitter so we'll break off like into
our own thing that way at the end of the
day we all come back to one goal which
is the brand WG so we pushed that but uh
yeah that's what I got triple crispy
sauce melanthius
did you listen to any of the episodes
before like a hundred no cuz because
Chris is Chris's intro was crispy tall
lanky butthole stanky yeah I got fired
epps Anna so I had a phase that people
listen that guy was smelly ass - like
episode 120 or something like if any if
he meets any type of the road yes
yeah everything Donna Chris just said
check out the shirts we are raising
money for a great cause anything you you
don't even have to buy if you just like
shit'll and we yes share the link
retweet it put up an Instagram stuff
like that it's much appreciated we try
to do this stuff like once or twice a
year
yeah and then jump in the varmint yeah
jump into the valor and tournament when
we get it we got to open up the
registration this week and then we'll
have everything ready for June 6th will
be shoutcasting it Chris and I will not
be participating because we want to get
we want to step back you know we want
the people we don't everyone else
everybody ridiculous yeah but there's
there's a lot of people that we know
that are just like inherently good at
these games like we are - we're not bad
at these games I would consider us
pretty decent valorem players but like
and let everyone else have fun well
we'll shoutcast it will make it fun
I will say right now l is way better of
a BS player than I am way to jump on the
team jump on the ILP team Wow she's
wither than I am
sometimes sometimes all right every time
I see cuz I can't do I like for me I
don't like that fast-paced us and every
time you're doing you know modern
warfare or apex or any of that stuff I'm
just like that's that's true fast-paced
for me that's what I think that like
tartar cop is like perfect for me
because you have that mix of like moving
with speed but at the same time you have
stealth it's almost like hunting like
I've never been hunting before so I'll
put a disclaimer on that but it's the
same way like you sit in the bush and
you wait for some like morons to decide
run past you and you just pop them I
mean that sounds miserable like if I die
the guy I I mean I get no one's in a
bush a bush
sounds like a full-time camper yeah I
mean big-time bush I mean just can't lay
on the ground I'm gonna be in a bush
everything what else do I have to plug
Oh easy our twitch twitch on TV
backslash wicked you gaming I'm
streaming they're anywhere from two to
like four times a week we stream the
podcast live on Twitch every Thursday
night at 9:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
and you can check out more video content
at youtube.com slash wicked a gaming and
I would like to forego the rest of my
time your honor
- MJ and L okay what I want you guys do
i I want you guys to plug things now oh
look I get that I got podcasts on blood
running through my veins - I guess so oh
you can catch me on mixer Tuesday
through Friday 7 p.m. to 10 p.m. I'm
definitely definitely definitely playing
apex tomorrow night because Lobo comes
out oh hello
season five starts super ready for that
and then oh and I'll be giving out free
$10 gift cards on my stream so you can
join in on the fun issues of our paths
and then this weekend if you haven't
heard we have Escalade it's coming on
the show from will be stuff from gwg so
on Saturday morning 9 9 a.m. Pacific 12
p.m. Eastern you can catch us giving an
interview with Escalades and I'm going
to take their link and I'm gonna put
that also in the description below for
everyone else if they want to check that
out because you know they are amazing
group of ladies and you guys should
really listen to them and you know they
have a great great podcast and they have
great video
all they're playing cuz you know most
podcasts they're just sitting there
talking like we are now but they
actually have gameplay the whole entire
time which is really really nice cash
shows you how well all for them are as
gamers so everyone should really you
know check them out so thank you alright
MJ what about you bud he's done with
college for this yes sir yeah he can
find me on Twitch in about 20 minutes
that MJ is the boss I'll be live Tuesday
through Sunday 9:30 till probably about
2:00 or 3:00 a.m. grind kinga yep let's
see what snapchat beat 101 and then my
Twitter's baby MJ also Lords of gaming
dotnet best articles out there like I
always said what is the games of the
gold and PlayStation Plus the free games
of the month
Dizzy's in the chappie he knows the
snapchat plug was a good move like you
don't hear enough about you don't know
snapchat of tick-tock plugs you notice
that oh yeah a point Chris Chris go go
go Oh Oh Chris yeah I started in a
couple days ago mmm
and what is that you're just gonna leave
school leave it there
yeah I mean you got you got to follow
the account know what it's about I'm not
gonna give our secrets what do we do on
it no no a Twix a good game just search
around you'll find that's over the
Internet's not small guys you'll find it
nobody find us right now and everyone
everyone knows me it is now though go
ahead and check me out on Twitter Monday
to Friday if I am NOT here I am there
between 7:00 and 10:00 30 ish every
night SN al why do TV if it's any easier
for you to find me I actually do
sub only giveaways every month
the dollar gift cards to our subs thank
yous get discord the whole nine yards
got a lot of a lot of crazy stuff in the
works as I know some people in chat
follow me they make me drink over stupid
amount of water throughout the whole
entire day made me do that alcohol oh my
god to me earlier yeah he did that to me
too he was like he's like oh here's $5
drink I'm like yeah right now I'm you
know you can't be doing that on Twitter
can't be incentivizing oh no I can be
incentivizing via channel points to
drink water and eat that you finally if
you don't get caught no you got yes and
yes I had to change it over to the
regular thin Oreos because people were
making me eat too many and I was like
I'm gonna have diabetes by the time I'm
like 40 I gotta change this so but yes
that's that is that's if anyone has any
questions for any of our guests please
email us at roundtable stream team at
gmail.com thank you all of the chat for
hanging out
Martinez Lantern the infamous you know
Michael so many people I can't even name
them all I appreciate all the guys from
with you gaming that decided to you know
stop in all three of them you know I
this is this was a fun time we're gonna
have to definitely do this again when we
get to pax predator party oh my god it's
so much fun even MJ can come to that one
you just get a band that says it says
that I get free drinks for the whole
night and yes so yes and I'm not gonna
plug iron Lords because cog was hearing
he did it for me thank you
and everyone remember to or follow us on
Twitter that is table stream and
everyone remember to dream big keep
gaming and we'll see everybody soon keep
an eye on Twitter and on our on our
Twitter pretty much to see when we're
gonna be going live and who's gonna be
come up next so thanks again everybody
have a great one everybody face toodles
nice show forgot those function really
show